and thank you for joining us will Las
Vegas be the new home of A's baseball
right now a special session in the state
legislature underway discussing it
thanks for joining us at four I'm Brian
Loftus and I'm Vanessa Murphy and for
Kirsten State lawmakers are debating if
tax dollars should be used to build a
stadium on the strip
we have Team coverage 8 news now
reporter Ryan Matthey standing by with a
look at how professional sports are
impacting the Valley's economy but first
eight news now reporter Brian will joins
us here in the studio with more on
what's happening in Carson City Brian
Brian and Vanessa for their part the A's
are expected to pay well over a billion
dollars to get a Stadium built at the
site of the Tropicana Hotel the rest of
that money would come from taxpayer
dollars Senate Bill 509 would give the
A's up to 380 million dollars of Public
Funding to help build a thirty thousand
seat baseball stadium 180 million
dollars of that funding would come from
the state in the form of tax credits
Clark County would put up a bond for 120
million dollars that would be paid for
by taxes generated by the stadium now an
additional 25 million dollars would be
set aside for infrastructure
developments the debate continues in a
Committee hearing with Las Vegas
Convention and visitors Authority
president Stephen Hill
it provides you around Sports it
provides a counter-cyclical set of
events to what we have now it doubles
the number of professional sporting
events that we will have in Las Vegas or
just a few of the Milestones the bill is
currently in the state senate if they
pass it then it heads over to the same
thing in assembly since the legislative
Stadium plan doesn't directly raise
taxes the bill needs a simple majority
in the state and Assembly not a
two-thirds approval to pass now the bill
also calls for funding to provide
assistance to homeless people around
Clark County it also mandates that at
least 15 percent of the stadium project
be completed by small and local
businesses